earth has become an urban planet cities
are growing everywhere more than half of
the world's people already live in
cities by 2050 two out of three of us
will live in a city that has sobering
implications for the environment cities
consume vast amounts of food energy and
materials this ecological footprint can
extend far beyond the city's edge indeed
the land area needed to support a city
can be 200 times bigger than the area of
the city itself another challenge is
that cities are expanding into areas
rich in biodiversity that's because we
like to live in the same places that are
favored by plants and animals cities
alter the environment in dramatic ways
tons of concrete store Heat city centers
become heat islands that are warmer at
night and hotter by day urban areas are
noisy and artificial light means it
never gets really dark paved roads and
rooftops prevent water from soaking into
the soil that leads to flash floods and
lots of polluted runoff that can harm
streams and rivers but an urban planet
is not all gloom and doom when you put a
lot of people in one place you can
improve efficiency city dwellers can use
a lot less energy per person than people
living in rural areas doing it right
will require smart planning and one
thing is clear cities are here to stay
and the decisions we make today about
how we build and live in them will shape
generations to come